foreign
there's like an Apple box here not sure
why
so when someone is trying to tell me
something
with that happy New Year everybody
welcome back
and Welcome to our first briefing of
2023 I hope everyone had a peaceful and
um just a restful holiday season okay
with that I have one quick thing at the
top and then we'll get going as we
announced this past weekend the
president will travel to Covington
Kentucky tomorrow where he will deliver
remarks on how his economic plan is
rebuilding our infrastructure creating
good paying jobs that don't require a
four-year degree
and revitalizing communities that are
too often Left Behind the president will
be joined in Kentucky by Senate minority
leader Mitch McConnell Senator Jared
Brown Kentucky Governor Andy beshear and
Ohio Governor Mike dewine
their visit will highlight the
president's historic record of achieving
bipartisan results for the American
people we'll have additional information
to share about the president's trip
later today so stay tuned but lead but
leaders across the administration will
spend Wednesday highlighting the impact
of the president's economic agenda and
work to rebuild our nation's
infrastructure vice president Harris
will visit Chicago Secretary of
Transportation Pete Buda judge will
visit New London Connecticut and White
House infrastructure coordinator Mitch
Lander will visit San Francisco with
that okay
Z kick us off thanks very happy you're
um uh what are the president's been
watching the action going on the other
side of Pennsylvania right now uh and uh
does he uh have a preferred candidate
that's one way to put it look as you
know the president uh served as a U.S
senator for 34 years and he understands
how this process work he certainly will
not insert himself in that process look
we are looking forward to working with
uh Congressional colleagues including
Democrats Republicans and independents
this year and and the new Congress
obviously to continue to move uh the
country forward for the American people
continue to build on an economy uh that
that is working that because of the
president's policy if you think about
the bipartisan infrastructure
legislation that I just spoke about and
how that's bringing that brought both
sides together and really going to
deliver on an important an important
item of the bridge uh for uh for
kentuckians but also in the region so
that's going to be our Focus we're
certainly not going to insert ourselves
and and what's happening on the other
side of Pennsylvania Avenue I just have
a couple of mastery questions for you
questions um does the White House have
any response to the Israeli National
Security investors visit to the temple
mountain is constructive
yes uh so this is the the mosque that
you're talking about by the National
Security advisor there look so the
United States stands firmly and we've
been very clear for uh preservation of
the status quo with respect to the holy
sites in Jerusalem any unilateral action
that jeopardizes the status quo is
unacceptable and we will continue to be
uh steadfast on that and be very clear
on that and then uh separately does the
White House have to respect there's some
pretty sharp rhetoric coming out of
Beijing today in response to the testing
measures that the US and other countries
have put in place Chinese Travelers over
the last week or so as a white I've seen
that as any response to that yeah so
we've seen that look I I will not speak
for for China but I'll be but I'll but
I'll say this there's no cause for
retaliation here just because countries
around the world are taking prudent
Health measures to protect their
citizens that's what you're seeing from
us and others this decision is based on
public health and science this is coming
from our experts here and other
countries like Japan like South Korea
the UK France India Italy Malaysia are
also taking similar public steps here
the World Health Organization is calling
on China to release more data which is
vital to the identity to identify any
potential variants again there is no
need for retaliation this is something
that all all of us other countries are
doing to make sure that we are
protecting our citizens here
[Music]
before you ask your question I just
wanted to offer my condolences and the
administration's condolences to your
loss
um and it was we were all very sad to
hear about the passing of the executive
producer of this week of dag and I got
to meet him a couple of times he was a
incredibly kind and wonderful individual
and very smart and clearly passionate
about his work and served as a such a
mentor and so we you know our hearts and
prayers go out to the ABC News family to
his wife and his very young children and
again our condolences thank you very
much thank you
um you mentioned that the president
looks forward to working with
Republicans presumably once they get
their leadership sorted out uh now that
we do have in Congress in place so what
is the first order of business where the
president does look to try and work with
Republicans so I'm not going to get into
specifics on what uh the policies or
pieces of legislation is going to look
like we're going to wait for the new
Congress to kind of settle in and get
themselves uh get themselves situated
but what I will say is that the
president has always been very clear
he's been clear when he was a president
he was clear when he was U.S Senate
Senator he was clear on the campaign
trail that he is going to he's willing
to work with Republicans who are willing
to continue to deliver for the American
people and it's not just him this is
what the American American public said
very loudly and clearly after the
midterms they want us to work on a
common ground to deliver on on the needs
of of what's important for them and to
do it in the way that we're building the
economy from the bottom up in the middle
out is the president has said many times
and he wants to make sure we reward hard
work and playing and people and do this
and so that you know for people who are
playing by the rules and so this is very
important we want to make sure that we
address National Security concerns and
keep the American people safe and so you
know some of you may have seen the
president and the first lady on New
Year's Eve they were on on your network
and you heard the president it was just
something that he says all the time he
is he's an optimistic person he is very
optimistic on what lies ahead and how
we're going to move our country forward
does the president see this leadership
fight and have any takeaways from it in
terms of whether it may make it more
difficult to work with Republicans and
getting anything
you know I I will say this as you all
know we're going to go to Kentucky as I
just mentioned we announced it a couple
of days ago clearly uh that he's going
to go there it's going to be done in a
bipartisan fashion the bipartisan
infrastructure legislation the biggest
infrastructure investment since 1950s
you think about the most significant gun
reform in almost 30 years you think
about major China competitive
competitiveness legislation that's
already bringing more manufacturing jobs
back to America and key and key help for
veterans who were exposed to toxic
chemicals uh in in the line of duty
those are things that the president has
been able those are the historic pieces
of legislation that the history the
president has been able to do in a
bipartisan fashion and let's not forget
there are 200 pieces of legislation that
was done in a bipartisan way in just in
the first two years of his
administration so again he's optimistic
we're going to see that bipartisanship
uh tomorrow in in Kentucky when we're
out in the region and I think that's
incredibly important one more thing just
clear something up here on title 42 so
the court says the administration still
has the power to discontinue the policy
on its own if it so chooses I know
you've said you're complying with the
court you know deferring to them but is
it your understanding that the
Administration has this Authority or not
so the way we I know we haven't really
responded to this because we haven't had
a briefing so look um I'll say this just
to kind of give a reaction here on the
Supreme Court so look the Supreme
Court's order keeps the current title 42
policy in place while the court reviews
the matter in 2023 we will of course the
way that we see it comply with the order
and prepare for Court's review but at
the same time we're advancing our
preparations as I've mentioned to manage
the Border in a secure orderly and
humane way when title 42 eventually
lifts and will continue expanding legal
Pathways for immigration title 42 as you
all know you've heard us say this many
times before it's a public health
measure not in Immigration enforcement
measure and it should not be extended
indefinitely that is our view that is
what you've heard uh um a say as this
process has moved forward to truly fix
our broken immigration system though we
need Congress to act we saw the
president on his first day in office put
forth a comprehensive immigration uh
policy legislation and that he did that
to show how important this was how much
of a priority this was for him the
Supreme Court's order gives republicans
in Congress plenty of time we believe to
move past political finger pointing
pointing and and join our Democratic
colleagues to fix to work to to fix this
problem and come forth come come forth
with a comprehensive way to move forward
but do you agree with the court that you
have that Authority so yes the way the
way that I can speak to it from here I'm
not going to get into specifics the way
that we see it is we're going to comply
with what the Supreme Court uh justice
uh ruled in in its current in its
current form with time foreign there are
difference of legal opinion here look I
I'm just not going to get into a dive
into the legal opinion here or legal
kind of the legal back and forth on this
or any of the Nuance what I can say is
we're going to comply with what the
Supreme Court uh
announced and there they ordered just
last week so it's not going to get into
the opinion okay whether or not you
think you have that Authority or not I
it's not I'm just
Angelic from here that's what doj is
legal is doing the legal components of
this what I can say is we're going to
comply with the supreme court order as
it stands from last week
green
um just first quickly on on McCarthy
again I'm just curious if you know the
president made this case on the campaign
Trail last year about how you know
basically a vote for House Republicans
would mean a handing over leadership to
Mega extremism in his words do you feel
like this is an illustration of that in
some way and do you think it'll make
hard make it harder for you to get deals
done I mean the way that we see it is
that look if you think about the
midterms and if you think what was being
written about uh leading into leading
into the midterms last just a couple
months ago which was there was going to
be a red wave right that's what we kept
on hearing and that didn't happen right
what we saw was the American people said
very loudly and clearly they wanted us
to come together and work towards a
common ground right whether it's to deal
with the economy continue to build on
the the uh the president's Economic
Policy whether it's our national
security whether it's protecting women's
Women's Health Care all of those things
is what we heard from the American
people all protecting our democracy and
so the way we saw it and and it was
historical right if you think about a
Democratic president and what we saw
from those midterm elections we hadn't
seen anything like that in 60 years from
a Democratic president the success from
the midterms and it happened and it
occurred because of this president's
leadership because of his messaging
because of what we LED with right
because of all the policies that I just
mentioned including the bipartisan
infrastructure infrastructure
legislation right including the American
Rescue plan which was the first piece of
legislation that this President signed
to get our economy back on its feet and
so we see this very differently we see
that the American public has given us a
charge to work together to work in a
bipartisan way to continue to build on
what the president has been able to do
the last two years and did you invite
Kevin McCarthy to the January 6th
commemoration that you're holding here
on Friday I'll have more to say on what
uh on what what we're going to be doing
on January 6 just don't have anything to
share at this time okay and then just
one other topic do you have any reaction
to the um
uh the missile strike that killed uh
several dozen Uh Russian uh military uh
Personnel
um and uh to understand what it was U.S
uh arms that were used in that that
missile strike any any comment or or
concern so I don't have an assessment
for you on this I I would I would not
want to speak for Ukraine about their
own military operations again I just
don't have an assessment to share at
this time and has the president
discussed it with zelinsky at all don't
have anything to read out for you at
this time okay the event tomorrow is an
interesting contrast with what we're
seeing on the house floor today
um was that intentional were you
thinking through you know president
Senate minority leader a bipartisan law
the day after what I think everybody
expected was going to be a rather
chaotic day on the house tour you know
Phil it really speaks to what I just
kind of laid out for Trevor as we talk
about the results of the midterm
election and what the uh the American
people said very loudly and clearly they
want us to work together they want us to
work towards a common purpose that will
deliver for them but I'll say you know
I'll say this over over the holidays our
team was consistently engaged with
bipartisan Congressional leadership
Governors and local electeds across the
country to pull this trip together from
California to Kentucky and Ohio to
Illinois and also to Connecticut and so
this is important and and let's not
forget this is a bipartisan piece of
legislation this infrastructure
legislation that was done uh many many
months ago and so this is what we're
going to see you all are going to see
tomorrow certainly I'm not going to get
ahead of the president is going is going
to focus on this bridge which is a main
artery in that region that delivers uh
for not just the people of Kentucky but
for that region as well and so the
president will speak more about this uh
we'll you'll hear also a little bit more
from us later today on what that's going
to look like but again I think it can
highlight that we do big profound things
for the country when we work together
and I think that's an important message
to send to the American people
especially after the results of the
midterm elections then uh just one in
foreign policy officials across and
Clarity this last night just from the
podium the South Koreans were talking
about kind of expanding
efforts together in terms of deterrence
given what we see from North Korea um
can you kind of detail what exactly that
may be or what president Trump was
talking about so um I just want to be
very clear uh um just to reiter iterate
what the president said yesterday we're
not discussing joint nuclear exercises
the ROK is a non-nuclear uh weapon state
so just want to be very clear on what
the president was saying and it is very
much uh how how it stands but following
their meeting in Cambodia President
Biden and president oon tasked their
teams to plan for an effective
coordinated response to a range of
scenarios including nuclear use by North
Korea and so that is what the teams are
working on and and what president moon
was clearly referencing when he made his
comments yesterday and you I will point
you to his statement he also made that
clear in his most recent statement so
the United States is fully committed to
our alliance with the ROK and providing
extended deterrence through the full
range of U.S defense capabilities
um one quick follow-up on Phil and then
and then another
um
did the president over the holidays
Reach Out directly to Senator McConnell
to invite him to the event tomorrow as a
as a show of
the bipartisanship that you guys say so
as you know um
we do not talk about or lay out uh
private conversations with the
Congressional Congressional leadership
uh
sometimes we do but
I am
all right you may have caught me there a
little bit but look I'm just not I'm not
gonna you're gonna see them tomorrow uh
you'll be able to uh see for yourself
that relationship that has been you know
they've known each other for some time
now uh but look again I'm not going to
get into private conversation between uh
between the president and members of
Congress but what I can say and share
with you all of you is that our team was
consistently engaged with bipartisan
leadership as I just mentioned not just
in Congress but also uh with Governors
and local leaders and this is an
important issue right again let's not
forget
um what the American people said very
loudly they want us to continue to build
on um on policies like the president's
going to talk about tomorrow this
bipartisan infrastructure legislation uh
and you know want to be very serious
here when you think about infrastructure
it is connecting communities and that's
what uh one that is one of the vital
things that we will see tomorrow when we
are at the bridge and then one just real
quickly about the next trip the Mexico
City trip I imagine you guys are going
to do some sort of briefing later but do
you have some can you give us some sense
of uh you know what the what the agenda
is obviously trade but but immigration
title 42 what's the what's the message
and and and I admit I didn't I didn't I
don't have the details but apparently
there was some reporting this morning
that um that amlo had sent a letter or
some sort of communication to the U.S
this morning detailing what he wants to
be on the agenda so so as you as you
stated we'll have more details on the
trip including deliverables in the
upcoming days I'll say a little bit of
what we've already shared as you know
we're going to go on the 9th and the
10th the president's going to be
traveling to Mexico City for the North
American leaders Summit alongside
president Andres Manuel Lopez albertor
of Mexico and president Minister uh
prime minister Pardon Me Justin Trudeau
of Canada the nalls will be an
opportunity for President Biden prime
minister Trudeau and president of Mexico
to promote a common vision for North
America with concrete initiatives that
will address climate and environmental
challenges increase North America's
competitiveness protect the health and
safety of our citizens jointly respond
to irregular migration in the region and
advanced diversity equity and inclusion
as well we will as you as you noted as
we get closer to closer to the trip
we'll certainly have more uh to share
with all of you yeah quick one um where
Senators Rand Paul or JD Vance invited
to the event tomorrow I don't have
anything to share on who who was invited
um or not invited but I can tell you who
will be there tomorrow okay and um the
president I would point you to their uh
their offices
um and uh the president uh had said that
he was going to spend this lovely
holiday season talking to his family has
he decided whether or not to fund for
re-election and when uh will he tell us
oh goodness
so look as you know I have to follow
um the law in terms of what I can
discuss here we do believe in the rule
of law I know some of you had something
to say about that just a couple weeks
ago but we do believe in the rule of law
and we will respect it and we will honor
that uh hear from this Administration so
look you've heard the the president say
this directly after the most uh
successful first midterms for a
Democratic president as I just stated uh
in 60 years especially as we heard very
loudly from the American people and the
message that they sent and look you know
he has said that he intends to run
um and I'm certainly not going to get
ahead of of the president uh what I can
say is that his Focus will continue to
be and has always been on the American
people it is going to continue to be and
has and has always been on what we can
do to improve their lives it will
continue to be and it has always been
how do we build on his Economic Policy
how do we build an economy from the
bottom up in the middle out and how do
we continue to cut tax cut cut costs
when we think about health care when you
think about the inflation reduction act
when you think about the chips act and
making sure that we're bringing
manufacturing jobs back here into the to
the US which we're seeing uh
manufacturers doing so that's going to
be his Focus again I'm just going to
reiterate what I said I'm going to
reiterate what the president said he
intends to run and certainly as I know
from my job I'm not going to get ahead
of of any announcement just a tiny
holiday catch up or maybe not tiny at
all because it was is a giant meltdown
does the
um does the administration have any
thoughts about the Southwest Airlines
meltdown uh are you guys satisfied with
the performance of the airline
um and what is the administration going
to do to make sure the passengers are
made home yeah I have a couple things to
say on that I think that's a really good
question look Southwest Airlines failed
its customers Point Blank the Department
of Transportation will hold them
accountable to their commitments to make
their customers whole while every major
airlines face challenges from a
pre-Christmas storm that that wrecked
havoc on the aviation system all major
airlines except for one which is
Southwest clearly we're able to recover
quickly so Southwest Airlines
acknowledge that all cancellations
starting December 24th were controllable
in other words not weather related so
that means the airlines assumes
responsibility based on Southwest prior
commitments to custom customers the
airline must cover rebooking hotel rooms
meals and transportation to and from a
hotel what's more Southwest must make
their customers whole by paying for
Coach flights rental cars and trains to
get people to their final destinations
and Southwest must return baggage as
quickly as possible and reimburse
passengers up to three thousand and
eight hundred dollars in per provable
damage under southwest care the
transportation department is watching
they're monitoring this very very
closely to ensure that this all happens
and we'll see fines from Southwest if it
doesn't cover a cost
thank you Happy New Year Happy New Year
to follow up on Tam's question after we
saw thousands of flights over the summer
be canceled and delayed we heard a very
similar sentiment that you just said
from secretary Buddha judge that we have
to put more pressure on the airlines
that you know he thought that things
would get better by the holidays that
you're pressing the airlines for better
service
what did the administration do between
those failures and the failures we saw
over the holidays to try to make things
better so just a couple of things so
since 2020 to your question our
Administration has made it a priority to
help people get their money back from
Airline Airline disruptions the uh that
aggressive work has brought Real Results
for the American people in 2022 D.O.T
issued the largest consumer protection
fines against Airlines in U.S history
the Department of Transportation will
seek fines from from Southwest as I just
mentioned to make sure that they cover
cost as required and look our
Administration is going to continue to
uh to press for long-term solutions that
is this is something that we are
committed on we're committed to you
heard the president speak about this
making sure that you know that customers
who are kind of left Left Behind
essentially uh uh get get really get be
are able to recover in whole so just a
couple two things I just want to lay out
in June secretary Buddhist called a
meeting of Airline CEOs to address the
unacceptable rate of cancellations and
delays we saw during the summer and
demanded more realistic scheduling and
better customer service as a result
cancellations have decreased
significantly since the summer with the
exception of Southwest over the holidays
like this remember all the other
airlines were able to get back on their
feet except for this one Airline as
which is Southwest so look these
continued problems are unacceptable and
we will be very clear about that and
you've heard directly from the
Department of Transportation from
secretary Buda judge over the last
couple days on this this specific issue
Congressman rocana said that this mess
with Southwest could have been avoided
and you know he he questioned why his
recommendations to Buddha judge six
months ago were not followed do you have
any response I
I just laid out what um look we respect
secretary um part of me Congressman
rocana uh he is uh he is a friend of the
administration we've worked very closely
with him but I just laid out how
seriously we have taken this since 2020
uh and the actions that we took
certainly in 2022 over the summer as you
mentioned the cancellation and we have
said very very loud and clear this is
like unacceptable what we have seen what
we're seeing from Southwest uh
specifically look the work continues and
we are always welcome always welcoming
to hear from others on how we can better
help to improve this but again this is
something that we have taken very
seriously we've laid out specific steps
on how to move forward here uh and I'm
sure you all saw the letter that boot
secretary Budu judge wrote to Southwest
CEO about this particular issue and we
are going to work make this a priority
in making sure that we get people their
money back into their pockets who are
affected by this this is a serious that
we take very seriously just a couple on
house leadership I know you said the
president wasn't going to insert himself
into the leadership vote but to follow
up on Zeke's question has he been
observing
um the vote today at all oh look I can't
speak to uh if uh if he's been watching
uh the vote today what I can say is he's
had a a pretty busy schedule uh he did
the pdb this morning as you all know
he's had um internal meetings with his
staff all day but look this is you know
I say this because this is something he
truly believes he has been he was a
Senator right he understands how this
process works and he's just not going to
insert himself he's going to let the
process play out
and continue to do the the work of the
American people and then just finally
regardless of how it shakes out does the
president believe that House Republicans
should find a way to push George Santos
out of Congress look this is something
that the House Republicans the
Republican conference they will have to
decide what they owe to the American
people in terms of standards and service
that is something that they have to
decide on and so we leave it to the
Republican Congress thank you I haven't
seen them online nice to see you happy
New Year I'm here a number of my
questions have already been answered so
I'm going to switch gears to something
else sort of a cultural moment occurred
last night with the NFL football game
and coincidentally the president will be
in the Cincinnati area tomorrow where uh
the player and Paul Tamlin is is
hospitalized does the president or the
White House have any reaction to uh that
particular incident and where it stands
with a player safety and just how this
um really had a big impact on sports
fans in the United States so certainly
the president
um uh has seen the horrific news of
Demar Hamlin's Cardiac Arrest during the
game last night it was as I said
horrific and millions of people uh saw
that across the country so you know I'll
say that um you know we hope his
condition and his health improves
quickly and like the rest of the nation
our thoughts and prayers are are with
him his family and uh and his teammates
I'm not gonna get ahead and lean into
any hypotheticals but what we are
praying for and hoping for is that his
health improves
welcome hi thank you so much
um
I had a question here first on
nominations the White House
um announced this morning that Eric
Garcetti will be re-nominated to be
mastered the ambassador to India can you
talk a little bit about what the White
House believes has changed since he was
nominated
say that last part what just what has
changed to things that this confirmation
process will go a little more smoothly
than it did last so look as secretary
blinken said very recently our
relationship with India is crucial and
it's consequential so we see this as a a
very important uh nomination and has
been as you you know been reported we'll
continue to seek uh the confirmation of
of Mayor Garcetti who has who was as you
all know voted out of a committee
unanimously and with strong bipartisan
support to serve as ambassador to India
and that's important as we're talking
about bipartisanship as we're talking
how we're going to move forward and this
is what you saw with his particular
nomination so we see this as he is well
qualified mayor Garcetti to uh to serve
in this vital role and we're hopeful
that the full Senate will confirm him uh
promptly again he was uh he was a voted
out of committee in a in a unanimously
uh with in unanimously with strong
bipartisan support
um and then I also wondering if you
could talk a little bit about
the president's relationship with
Representative Steve scalise
oh I I you know um would it be careful
here as I said we're not going to insert
ourselves I feel like this is where this
is going
you know I just want to be careful
um uh in what's happening right now uh
look the president as you know was vice
president he was a senator for 34 years
he has um many relationships with
members of congress not going to get
into into details here about any one
specific relationship we are going to
allow the Republican conference to you
know have their process play out and
we're certainly I'm just not going to
say it more that's one final question
um in in November President Biden said
that he had completed um part of my
physical and would be I'm getting it by
the end of the year
um has the president completed his
physical and well the White House
releasing here to start with your last
comment first we will be releasing his
full physical in in a transparent way
the way that we did the first time
around as president so that is going to
happen I've said that before from here I
don't have a timeline for you it's going
to happen in the next probably a couple
of months but I'll say this the doctor
has said this as well is that the
president is in good health he isn't
he's he's very active you see it for
yourself with your own eyes but we will
be sure to be transparent just like we
were the first go-around when he in his
first year as his presidency thank you
Stephen thanks thanks Kareem um it's
been a century since the House of
Representatives has failed to choose the
speaker on the first ballot since then a
couple of modern Phoenix agencies have
been essentially uh offered by the
Congress to deal with modern potential
problems one is a presidential
succession another would be intelligence
briefings does the absence of a speaker
of the house at this moment is there
anything we should know about how the
White House views that from a
constitutional or into a branch stamp
well look it's a good question a little
bit of a let the process play out right
it's a little bit of a hypothetical here
I don't have the specifics on how that
works out but look we have to see what
the Republican conference does again
we're not going to interfere we're going
to let that process play out I just
don't want to kind of dive into any
hypotheticals until we see what occurs
today broadly since January 6th the
president has talked about how foreign
leaders have approached him and asked
him about the health of American
democracy is there a message the White
House would stand overseas today as
people look and see that the House of
Representatives has failed to choose its
speaker does it portend gridlock the
next two years the inability of
government to function here in the
United States look I think the president
would point to what the American people
have been very clear about what the
American people said you know and I said
this earlier look you know the outcome
that was reported by many and and kind
of uh said by by many folks just just in
this space in the DC bubble was that
there was going to be a red wave right
that it was going to be a very different
outcome and the American people were
very clear they want us to continue to
fight for our democracy they want us to
continue to to work on an economy that
builds uh you know that doesn't leave
anybody behind and and building economy
from the bottom up middle out and I
think that's important it's important
that that's what the American people
said very loud and clear uh look
um you know again not going to insert
myself here or the president's not
certainly got into himself in what's
happening today we're going to let the
process play out I don't know where it
is currently as I'm standing in front of
you behind this Podium but
um you know this is something that the
Republican conference has to figure out
on there on their own and they will do
so
thank you Kareem happy New Year happy
New Year happy New Year not a daddy yet
uh we're in the birth month
will Joe Biden announce a re-election
I thought no wait I thought you were
gonna you were gonna ask for my okay to
name your daughter Karine I thought
that's where that thought that's where
we were going here
yeah
um
I think Korean sounds sounds just as
good too okay
[Music]
um
I'll follow up to some of the
immigration uh news from over the break
does anybody around here think that the
southern border is secure
what I can tell you is this is a
president has been working since day one
uh to work on border security uh to make
an immigration a priority that's why he
put forth a comprehensive immigration uh
reform plan legislation and here's
here's the thing as the president is
coming forward and trying to come up
with Solutions but the difference here
is that you have Republicans as you know
who are doing political stunts and you
know and we've called that out over and
over and over again and the president is
willing is willing to work with Congress
Republicans Democrats Independents to
work on these issues that matter to the
American people but this is an issue
that the president has taken very very
seriously since day one of his
administration what roughly seven
thousand migrants Crossing every day
illegally does the White House believe
the border is secure look I've told you
what we have done what we have made this
a priority uh to make sure are they
working to make sure that there's border
security measures look
look here's the thing Peter
the president has taken historic actions
right that no other president has been
able to do when you think about the 23
000 agents uh that he has been able uh
we have been able to put out there to
deal with uh the issue that we're seeing
at the border and that is something that
he did without a lot of Republican
support right make sure that we are
dealing with a real issue when you think
about the Smugglers really putting a
plan in place that we deal with the
Smugglers right and we have to be very
careful here Peter on how we talk about
this because if we talk about it in a
way that is misinformation then it helps
the Smugglers and so these are the
issues that the president has taken
incredibly seriously and again I will
say this I just said it moments ago he's
willing to work with Republicans he's
willing to work with Democrats he's
willing to work with Independents to
work on this issue to move forward with
his comprehensive plan that he put
forward on day one of his administration
and another topic with the new uh
Republican majority coming in the house
oversight committee is laying out their
new investigations and they claim to
have evidence that Jill Biden lied to
the American people about his
involvement in his family's business
schemes did he
so look
um I've said this before and I'll say it
again House Republicans promised that
fighting inflation during the midterms
was going to be their number one
priority that's what they said was
important to them and that's what they
said that they wanted to do but instead
what they're doing is uh wanting to do
an investigation on the president and
his family that is their focus they
don't want to focus on the American
people and their family they want to
focus on political division they want to
focus on uh something that the American
people do not want to see as we saw from
the midterm elections look I'm I'm not
going to get into you know get into the
specifics of any of the oversight here
we have a White House Council that's
going to my colleagues who are going to
deal with this so I will point you to
them and you know again I'll point you
one more thing I'll point you to
tomorrow tomorrow we're going to see a
uh you know a trip an event where that's
going to be done in a bipartisan way so
there's ways of to move forward for the
American people for American families in
a way that works
and Karine last week's visitor law
release showed
it wasn't Sam bankman freed and a White
House official Steve richetti in this
case this was his fourth meeting of the
year I'm wondering uh
I'm giving this the first briefing since
then if you can give us any sort of
summary of what has been discussed in Mr
Beckman creates meetings with the White
House over the course of the year yeah
so let me give you a couple of a couple
of a few rundowns here
um so as we've previously confirmed as
you know I know you're following this
very closely these meetings included
Steve rashetti and Bruce Reed the
meetings focused on pandemic prevention
related to Sam Beckman Freed's
foundation and general information on
the cryptocurrency industry and crypto
exchanges look you know the
Administration has been clear about the
need for Congress to take action when it
when we talk about addressing
cryptocurrency the president as you know
released an executive order on this
topic just last March and the president
released a framework for protecting
consumers last fall and last November
secretary Yellen renewed this
administration's call for Congress to
take action so you know as you know the
White House regularly engages with
officials from a range of Industries and
sectors including leaders in business
and labor and non-profits you know again
this meeting with Sam benfried was
focused on pandemic prevention related
matters and cryptocurrency and crypto
exchanges when you were last uh general
information thank you I think you said
that you you couldn't comment on whether
the president has any view about whether
Democrats or democrat aligned groups
should consider returning some of the
donations Mr Bank in free Maine I'm just
circling back on that to see whether
that's still the case because he has no
view on whether this is still the case I
don't have anything to share or any
change of my comments that I've made
before on this looking forward to this
year a lot of the last two years
accomplishment that you talk about are
seen less likely an invited Congress
needs us to say can you give us a sense
of what you see as a sort of Baseline
Target for Success from your view in
2023 what do you hope to get out of a
year with the divided Congress when some
of the things that he relied on sort of
you know heavily in the last Congress
won't really be available to him this
time around I mean look I just mentioned
you know we're gonna be um
in Kentucky tomorrow with Mitch
McConnell the Senate minority leader
um and I think that's important I think
that shows uh how how it is important
for the president to show that
bipartisanship right it is important uh
to show that how the bi-person
infrastructure legislation is going to
make a real difference to Americans
across the country and so I think that
um
I know there's a lot of doubt and I know
there's tends to be a lot of work this
is politics there tends to be a lot of
negative negative uh uh kind of thinking
on how we move forward but look this is
a president as Senator as vice president
uh who has worked across the aisle and
has been successful at that again I laid
out some key historic we're talking
about historic pieces of legislation
that will change
the lives of American families across
the country and so that that matters so
we're going to continue to do that we're
going to continue to work with Democrats
Republicans Independents who are willing
to continue that work that he has done
the last two years on building on his
economic policy it does not end it
doesn't end in the last Congress it
hopefully will continue in a new
Congress are there any particular topics
what do you think I'm not so I'm not
just I'm not going to get into specifics
right now I'm not going to get ahead of
the president on what what that's going
to look like what I can say is when it
comes to lowering costs medical medical
costs for the American people as we
started to do a couple you know with the
inflation reduction act we want to
continue to do that right as it comes to
making sure we're creating good paying
union jobs clearly we want to continue
to do that we want to continue to fight
inflation which is the president's
number one economic uh priority so all
of those things still stand and it's
just a different year
or Korean I want to kind of piggyback
off of Steven's questions
um but today is a very newsy day on the
hill and the number 218 for the second
time is elusive for Kevin McCarthy what
do you say to the American public
as we're still figuring out what's
happening on Capitol Hill and this is
not just about a vote it could be a
constitutional issue look I just don't
want to again want to be really careful
here not going to you know you
understand the power of the podium here
not going to insert myself on something
that is currently happening on the other
side of Pennsylvania not going to get
involved not going to name names just
going to let that process move forward
uh and uh and you know this is something
also that the president understands like
this is a process that that they have to
decide on but how do you reassure how
does the other side of Pennsylvania
Avenue reassure the American public as
the democracy is going through Growing
Pains some may say there are cracks in
democracy how does this White House
reassure the American public as all of
this is going on so look I mean look
separately inside to what's going on as
we're talking about our democracy and
the president has been very clear we
have to continue to fight for it this is
something that he will continue to do
every day and we have to protect our
democracy this is something that
president has spoken about in in
speeches that you have covered April
yourself and how important it is to do
that and he feels as a president of the
United States he needs to speak loud and
clear about that but again let's not
forget the American people as you're you
know alluding to is very much paying
attention to this right they want us to
continue to fight for our democracy they
want us to continue to protect our
democracy I don't want to again don't
not going to get into what's happening
on the again on the other side of
Pennsylvania but this is as it relates
to our democracy this is something that
the president takes incredibly seriously
lastly at the very least Hakeem Jeffries
will be minority leader of a house has
the president talked to him recently
what is there a relationship Etc
I don't have a call to read out to you
but I can say that we are we are looking
forward to working with uh leader
minority leader Jeffries we see him as a
partner in this he is incredibly
impressive the president believes he's
incredibly impressive and we look
forward to working very closely with him
as we have been these past two years and
I think it's it's important right it's
important to see that type of
representation at that level but aside
from that Hakeem Jeffries is is a
brilliant a thinker a great legislator
and again we are we are you know
congratulate him on his uh on his new
role and we'll continue to work closely
with him
thank you Happy New Year Happy New Year
I wanted to ask you about is the first
district of this year what are the
foreign policy priorities for the
president for this year
it's for our goals or for for this year
so um so Jake Sullivan our national
security advisor spoke to this very
recently when he spoke at Carnegie just
last month actually so this is a
decisive decade which is what he said
and we are focused on how we compete
vigorously to advance our interest while
building diverse coalitions to address
the biggest challenges of our time and
in 20 if you look at 20 2022 just alone
as a standalone President Biden hosted
and met with leaders of of the Americas
of Africa of Southwest Asia the Middle
East and the Pacific Islands that is
something that the president did in just
one year alone he's attended very
consequential if you think about it more
more uh kind of more holistically the G7
G20 and NATO Summits this year you will
continue to see us enhance our strategic
position over the Long Haul by doing a
couple of several a couple of things
here that'll list out making a
significant investment in the sources of
America's domestic strength standing
with Ukraine and standing up for the
principles of an international order
that protects sovereignty and
territorial integrity and rejects
aggression and in Europe and in Europe
and also around the world
protecting Americans from threats at
home and around the world as well
whether it's terrorism or cyber attacks
and building flexible Coalition
worldwide on food security climate
technology and other another key issue
so this is how the president sees his
foreign policy moving forward this is
what we've been able to do in the last
in the first two years and again so this
is incredibly important to the president
president sees any Prospect for peace in
Ukraine this year so look we've been
very clear about this when as we talk
about uh Ukraine and them moving forward
and basically and you know you've heard
us say this over and over again nothing
about Ukraine without Ukraine and so
that's how we see this approach and and
that is the consistent consensus of this
Administration we all support a just
piece that is something that we all
support you heard the president uh say
those very words uh at the um press
conference the the two plus two that he
did when President zielinski made his
first trip in 300 days uh since the war
the aggression uh Russia aggression
started uh the mo but when we talk about
just peace that must include U.N
principles of sovereignty and
territorial integrities I just laid out
as we look at our 2023 goals it's a hard
it it is hard to take seriously the idea
that Russia has prepared for good faith
diplomacy when they are doubling down
and you guys are reporting in this they
are doubling down on annexing uh
Ukrainian territory and insisting they
they get to keep it and that's what
they're doing so that's not a basis for
real diplomacy at all so our job is to
keep supporting Ukraine on the
battlefield so that they're in the best
position in the best position to
negotiate at the table when that does
occur and finally on Sunday the last
number of gone American movements held a
protest in front of the White House
against the recent restrictions the
Taliban has imposed and caused education
uh what is the president's message to
these afghan-american women so we stand
with Afghan women and condemn the
taliban's indefensible decision to
restrict women's education and their
rights and so as we have made clear
these actions by the Taliban will
further alienate them from the
International Community and deny them
the legitimacy that they so desire and
so we remain in touch with our partners
and allies on this issue and will
continue to take steps to advance our
shared efforts to support Afghan women
and girls and provide a robust
humanitarian support to the people in
Afghanistan and we will be steadfast
about that thank you thank you Happy New
Year happy New Year
um you see White House of concern it's
all about the Israel and Russia seems to
be the new Israeli government and the
Putin government of closing ranks it
seems quite quite openly and just a very
quick other question do you have
anything on the possible kishida
by that here at the White House so on
your first question so look you know
we're I'm not going to speak for Israel
here but the U.S position remains clear
it's basically a little bit of what I
laid out just moments ago Russia's war
in Ukraine is a violation of
international law and serves as a threat
to Global Peace and security the United
States will support Ukraine as long as
it takes in the face of this unprovoked
war of aggression and our our support
will continue for as long as it's needed
extremely close Ally Israel uh is I mean
I you don't want to speak for the
Israelis obviously but there's a
extraordinarily close Alliance so does
the United U.S not have any anything
borders for sale I mean we have said
this about many other countries right
who have been you know
um who have been where we have been
asked about their relationship with
Russia look we're just not going to
speak for them we're going to lay out
what's at stake and what's important in
this moment thanks
I will we'll have more to say about that
soon don't have anything right now sure
Korea thanks Karina yeah happy New Year
um yeah so the the president took credit
when gas prices were coming down now the
um the barrels leaving the Strategic
petroleum Reserve well that's ending the
president has not changed anything with
energy policy
um is the president's policies then just
taking credit for the gas prices rising
over the past uh seven days so look I I
want to make note here because this is
important uh We've made significant
progress in lowering the prices uh gas
prices specifically prices are down
nearly two dollars uh per gallon and are
lower today than they were one year ago
today this very day so we've seen a
slight increase yes over the past week
due to cold weather that shut down some
refineries but those refineries are
coming back online as some of you have
reported and president will continue to
do everything he can to keep lowering
costs for American families that is a
priority that you hear from him anytime
he talks about the economy and how he
wants to continue to lower cost for
Americans these refineries come back
online do you expect the gas prices to
come back down and the price of gas from
the president came into office was 2.39
I know but I'm talking about one year
ago and that was one year ago was not
when he came into office right so uh and
we have been able to lower the price uh
by uh by 2 nearly two dollars per gallon
and let's not forget one of the reasons
one year ago we were dealing with this
almost one year ago uh was uh you know a
Putin's war and which caused uh gas
prices uh to uh to increase and that
started in February of just last year
February 24th to be exact and so that's
what I'm talking about we've been able
to do that work to bring uh costs down
by nearly two to two dollars a gallon
look we expect once those refineries are
are getting back online uh that prices
will continue uh to decrease
thanks Karine back on the president's
trip to Mexico in the next few days what
is his message or will his message be
when he's there to would-be migrants who
may be confused about what the United
States immigration policies are right
now given the back and forth over title
42 and is there any specific action that
he wants president Lopez over to order
to take to help lower the number of
legal border crossings so look I'm not
going to get ahead of what's going to be
discussed or what's going to be on the
agenda we'll certainly have more to
share in upcoming days as we get closer
to the trip on January 9th look at
irregular mag migration is certainly one
of the key issues facing our Hemisphere
and it will certainly be one of the
important uh important topics of
discussion at the nulls right that is
something that certainly will be
discussed the president is going to look
forward to is looking forward to meeting
with Mexico and Canada to continue
coordinating a regional response which
you've seen over the past several months
to irregular migration in the region
include shooting through the continued
implementation of the principles
outlined in Los Angeles Angela's
Declaration on migration and protection
so we have been working with the two
countries for this past year or so on
dealing with irregular migration that is
going to continue certainly not going to
get ahead ahead of that there's a weird
noise happening
okay
when it comes to the president's
legislative agenda do you have any sense
of when the state of the union is going
to take place do you expect that to be
this long that's a good question uh I
don't have anything to share with you as
you know the state of the union is an
important opportunity for the president
to lay out his vision to in front of the
not just Congress but to the American
people for for this year and so I know
he looks forward to doing that as he did
last year just don't have anything to
share on that good for us to invite him
right the speaker does have to invite
the president but perhaps the president
would like to do it this month versus
next month the speaker you're right the
speaker does have to invite them so
don't want to get ahead of that process
okay thanks Corinne uh DC mayor Bowser
and her inaugural speech called on
President Biden to end work from home
for federal government employees or turn
over vacant government building she said
we need decisive action by the White
House to get most federal workers back
to the office most of the time or
realign their vast Property Holdings
from used by the local government
nonprofits businesses or she said any
user willing to revitalize it does the
White House have a response to Mayor
Bowser and has anybody spoken to her
about this proposal that she wants so it
just is this was yesterday yesterday so
I haven't checked with the team to see
if anybody has talked to her about this
or connected about this but increasing
the supply of affordable housing is a
priority of this Administration as you
know we've talked about it many times
over this past two years that's why the
president put forth the housing Supply
action plan and and that was to ease the
burden of housing costs over time by
using a mix of administrative and
legislative actions to boost the supply
of quality housing in every Community uh
so uh you know I don't have any
announcement to make from here or to any
response really uh to um to Mayor Bowser
but clearly this has been a priority um
for this President which is why he put
forth uh this plan this action plan
specifically on the issue of federal
workers and his Christmas speech on
December 23rd the president said things
are getting better covid no longer
controls Our lives our kids are back in
school people are back to work what does
he see as the future of federal work in
D.C for the federal Workforce in terms
of employees working at home versus
working in the office given the large
numbers of employees and the large
numbers of buildings that they work in
in this city and what that means for the
downtown area here no very good question
don't have an announcement to make at
this point look we we you know we listen
to The Experts right we certainly follow
uh follow the signs and listen to The
Experts just don't have anything to
announce today on any changes to that um
you know to that particular you know as
it relates to Federal buildings and uh
and federal workers but look just to
reiterate what the president said we are
in a different place than we were when
he walked into this Administration he
put together a comprehensive uh a a
comprehensive
um covid you know vaccination plan that
made a difference that helped put for
put our economy back on its feet and
look at us today I remember you guys
some of you were here for Jen's first
briefing there were 14 of you masked up
and look where we are two years later we
are in a different place and so uh I
think that's important to note we are
going to continue to you know share our
message with the American people to get
that new vaccine it is important it will
help it will help continue to get us
back into a place where it doesn't
disturb Our Lives the way it did two
years ago we know the tools that work we
know uh what we need to do and so we
need to make sure that we continue to
communicate with the community the
American people on getting that vaccine
and and so we'll continue to have that
conversation that's great oh okay great
question on Pope Benedict Korean Pope
Benedict question all right okay all
right um I'll take um
sure sure I'll take your go ahead Happy
New Year too happy New Year actually two
two okay uh one
um
yeah all right I'm gonna start this all
over yes let's start his funeral is
Thursday the light Pope Benedict his
funeral is Thursday is the U.S sending a
delegation to Rome do you know so let me
just first say because we haven't been
able to uh be on the record on this uh
since the passing of the Pope so as the
president said in his statement as I'm
sure you saw he joins Catholics and so
many others around the world in mourning
the passing of Pope uh Emeritus Benedict
XVI he will always remember the Pope's
generosity and me and meaningful
conversation they had when he visited
the Vatican in 2011 so to answer your
question uh the U.S ambassador to the
holy see Joe Donnelly will represent the
United States at the funeral of the Pope
in line with the wishes of the late Pope
and the Vatican this is what this is
what their requests were this is what
their wishes were and so uh that's what
you'll see from the US you're following
up what did I know you read a statement
there but what did Pope Benedict mean to
President Biden as a Catholic
you know for president uh as you know he
takes um his faith very seriously this
is someone who is uh passionate about
his faith that's not something I even
need to tell you you know this for
yourself and um he again he he remembers
the pope as generosity and his
meaningful conversation they had when
they visited uh when he when the
president visited the Vatican and back
in 2011 and so that's something that the
president remembers and holds very uh
close uh close to Heart
okay all right guys what a technical
issue
all right well guys I'll see you on the
road tomorrow and we'll be back in the
briefing room on Thursday thanks
everybody thank you